i want to get quick analysis uh joe
biden did his drive up town hall tonight
uh ari fleischer bring you in for the
analysis not one question about
the months of saying it's hysterical
xenophobia and fear-mongering ari
uh cnn fake news that in the tank for
biden i can't even ask that question
yeah no question on that sean no
question on why did you say in the oval
office in january of 2017 that the logan
actually invoked against
michael flynn and when he was asked
about franking fracking by a voter and a
voter said to him
are you against fracking he said no i'm
not against fracking and then anderson
cooper followed up and he did say then
wait a minute you previously said you
wanted to get rid of it
he said well i will so basically joe
biden in the space of five seconds said
i'm not against it now but i will be
against it i want to get rid of it
he's still all over the map when it
comes to that basic issue of american
energy independence largely brought to
us via fracking
really important to pennsylvania and he
flips again on the issue performance
again tonight
mandatory mask he flap flipped and
flopped back and forth again on the
issue of masks
but in this critical time period where
the president 10 days after the first
case of coronavirus
implemented the travel ban 10 days first
case
in the u.s then the quarantine first in
50 years
uh he spent months calling it you know
historical xenophobia fear mongering
now one of the questions i like to know
did he do it because he's
wanted hunter to get another 1.5 billion
dollar deal from the bank of china
legitimate question again he's not been
asked
yeah and in that issue the democrats
have been all over the map as well
remember nancy pelosi
pelosi and the mayor of new york city de
blasio urging people to go out to
chinatown
because they wanted to make the case
that republicans were bigots and
we republicans didn't want people to go
to chinatown so they encouraged get out
get out that's the end of february
you know the revisionism that the
democrats want to tell on how
much confusion there was about corona
from the beginning by
everybody now they wanted to sweep that
under the rug